ZERO-TOLERANCE?
LET ME KNOW ON TWITTER.
@BretBaier.
USE THE HASHTAG #SpecialReport
OR ON FACEBOOK AT
Facebook.com/BretBaierSR.
G.O.P. LEADERS HOPE TO TAKE
ACTION ON IMMIGRATION REFORM
LEGISLATION THIS WEEK.
AND PUT AN END TO AN ISSUE THAT
THREATENS TO TURN INTO A PUBLIC
RELATIONS DISASTER.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL IS ON
CAPITOL HILL TONIGHT.
>> THE ZERO-TOLERANCE
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS MAKING
SOME REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> IT'S CLEAR THIS IS A
SYMPATHETIC, TUGS AT YOUR
HEARTSTRINGS PICTURE AND
NARRATIVE, BUT I THINK IT'S MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
>> IT IS INCONSISTENT WITH OUR
AMERICAN VALUES TO SEPARATE
THESE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
>> ARIZONA REPUBLICAN
SENATOR JEFF FLAKE SENT THIS
LETTER TO THE SECRETARIES OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
" THERE IS PRESSURE FROM THE LEF
" THERE IS PRESSURE FROM THE LET
" THERE IS PRESSURE FROM THE LE.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAS OFFERED A
BILL TO BAN SEPARATING FAMILIES.
BIG I NEVER THOUGHT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WOULD
BE SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS, INFANTS FROM
THEIR PARENTS, NURSING MOTHERS
FROM THEIR INFANTS.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP IT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MET TODAY
WITH ROB WITHIN SENATORS RICHARD
SHELBY AND SHELLEY MOORE CAPITO,
WITH MR. TRUMP WANTING FUNDING
FOR THE BORDER WALL AND SHALL BE
TRYING TO PASS FUNDING BILLS IN
A BIPARTISAN FASHION.
ACROSS THE CAPITAL, HOUSE
LAWMAKERS EXPECTED TO CONSIDER
TWO DIFFERENT IMMIGRATION REFORM
PLANS THIS WEEK.
A CONSERVATIVE MEASURE FROM
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN BOB GOODLATTE
AND A CAREFULLY CRAFTED
COMPROMISE BASED ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FOUR PILLARS.
>> BORDER SECURITY IN THERE.
IT'S GOT FUNDING FOR THE WALL
THAT THE PRESIDENT REALLY WANTS.
IT'S GOT THE TECHNOLOGY BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
MEET WITH HOUSE REPUBLICANS
TOMORROW NIGHT TO PERSONALLY
MAKE THE CASE FOR ADDRESSING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
McCALL SAYS LAWMAKERS MUST GET
IT DONE.
>> AS I GET BRIEFED, THE THREATS
OF POTENTIAL TERRORISTS AND DRUG
CARTELS AND ALL THE OTHER STUFF,
>> ON THE ISSUE OF SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM THE PARENTS, TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ HAS INTRODUCED
EMERGENCY LEGISLATION THAT CALLS
FOR HIRING MORE BORDER
IMMIGRATION JUDGES, BUILDING
TEMPORARY SHELTERS TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER, AND FOR
FAMILIES DETERMINED THAT SHOULD
NOT GET ASYLUM, DEPORTING THEM
WITHIN TWO WEEKS.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
PENDING SHOWDOWN BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE SENATE
WERE CHINESE TELECOM FIRM Z TE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A PLAN.
THE SENATE, THE PRESIDENT'S
ALLIES LOOKING TO BLOCK THE
DEAL.
IT'S INCLUDED LANGUAGE INSIDE A
GIANT DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION BILL
COMING UP FOR VOTE THIS EVENING.
LAWMAKERS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
REVIVING THE COMPANY THAT'S BEEN
ALLEGED TO HAVE WORKED WITH BOTH
IRAN AND NORTH KOREA.
DEFINITELY A SHOWDOWN BETWEEN